AMINA MANSOUR: Hello, everyone.
My name is Amina Mansour,
and I'm a Solutions Architect
at Google Cloud.
Scott Surovich, who is the
Global Container Engineering
Lead at HSBC, will be
joining me later for a Q&A.
With the growing
interest and adoption
of hybrid and multicloud
architectures,
I find myself working
with a lot of customers
that are looking for guidance
on architecting their platforms
and choosing where
their applications
and services reside.
Today we will briefly review
the difference between hybrid
and multicloud,
then I will present
some of the more common patterns
we've seen with our customers.
And for the interesting
part of the talk,
we will have a Q&A with
Scott to share his experience
and insights with
hybrid and multicloud.
So what is the difference
between hybrid and multicloud?
If we take hybrid
first, this is where
you have workloads
that are deployed
across multiple
environments, one
being a private
on-prem data center
and one in the public Cloud.
Multicloud, on the other
hand, combines at least two
public Cloud environments,
but you can also
have a private computing
environment as part
of your multicloud setup.
So really, multicloud is a
superset of hybrid Cloud.
We can put these patterns
into two buckets.
The first is
distributed deployment,
where the aim is to run the
application in the environment
that suits it best.
So each application runs
in a specific environment.
The second is
redundant deployment,
where you deploy
the same application
in multiple environments.
Let's now look at the
different patterns.
The first pattern
we will talk about
is the tiered or
layered pattern.
The idea of it is to
focus first on deploying
front-end applications
to the public Cloud.
In this pattern, you keep your
back-end applications and data
in the private
computing environment.
Some advantages are
that this allows
you to start with the
less complex migrations.
You also benefit from
what Google Cloud knows
what to do well, so things like
load balancing and autoscaling.
And you keep your data
and back-end on-prem
for regulatory reasons.
Because you are communicating
across environments,
choose the Google Cloud Regions
and Interconnect location
closest to your data center.
Make sure to secure the
communication with VPN tunnels,
TLS, or both, and
establish a common identity
between environments
to authenticate across.
The second pattern is
the partition pattern.
It combines multiple
public cloud environments
that gives you the
flexibility to deploy
an application in the best
computing environment for it.
So application A is on Cloud 1
and application B is on Cloud 2
based on its dependencies
and Cloud services it uses.
Because of your presence
in multiple public Cloud
environments, you're
lowering your risk
and you have the flexibility to
change plans or partnerships.
You can also choose
which provider
to run an application or service
on depending on its needs.
Each additional environment
comes with additional overhead,
so weigh the advantages
against the overhead.
You should also minimize
dependencies across Clouds
so it doesn't
affect performance.
And focus less on portability
of your applications
and more on the portability
of your workflows
and having a unified
platform across providers.
Our third pattern is edge.
Running workloads in
the Cloud requires
that clients have fast and
reliable internet connectivity.
There are scenarios when you
cannot rely on continuous
connectivity, such as stores or
supermarkets that might be only
connected occasionally or use
links that are not reliable
enough for business
critical transactions.
With this pattern, you run time-
and business-critical workloads
locally at the
edge of the network
while using the Cloud for
all other kinds of workloads.
In an edge setup,
the internet link
is a non-critical
component that is
used for management purposes
and to synchronize your upload
data.
This helps you ensure low
latency and self-sufficiency
in cases when you cannot do that
due to network restrictions.
You also reuse existing
investments and equipment
at those edge locations.
And remember that increased
traffic to Google Cloud
is free, so that makes
it easier to communicate
back to the Cloud with
status or data syncs.
Two things to keep in
mind with this pattern--
you don't want to increase
the burden of management
of these edge locations
linearly with how many they are,
so you should have a centralized
control plane in the Cloud
to manage them all.
Also, the less dependencies
on the Cloud environment,
the more reliable and
faster your edge setup is.
Our fourth pattern is analytics.
In this pattern,
transactional workloads
stay on-prem and
analytics workloads
are in the public Cloud to
leverage best of read services.
Of course, the first thing that
comes to mind with this pattern
is BigQuery, which is a very
common reason why our customers
choose this pattern.
Analytics workloads often need
to process huge amounts of data
and can be bursty, so
they lend themselves
well to the public
Cloud and you don't
need to overprovision
on-prem anymore.
Google Cloud also
provides a rich set
of services to manage
data throughout its entire
lifecycle, ranging from
initial acquisition,
to processing and analyzing,
to final visualization.
Also you get to take advantage
of Cloud capabilities--
again, like I mentioned,
increased traffic and moving
data from the private computing
environment to Google Cloud
is free of charge.
And when you have existing
Hadoop or Spark workloads,
consider migrating
jobs to data PROC
and migrating existing
HDFS data to Cloud Storage.
Use queues to hand over data.
So things like Pub/Sub or maybe
even Cloud Storage buckets
to hand over the
data to Google Cloud.
Choose the transfer
approach that is best suited
for your data set size
and available bandwidth
for the initial data
transfer, and you
should use consistent
tooling and processes
across environments
to help increase
your operational efficiency.
This one is very common for
a majority of the patterns.
Last but not least is
the bursting pattern,
and it's the only
pattern discussed today
that fits in the redundant
deployment pattern bucket.
The idea of the Cloud
bursting pattern
is to use a private
computing environment
for the baseline load
and burst to the Cloud
temporarily when you
need that extra capacity.
While you can accommodate bursty
workloads in a classic data
center-based
computing environment,
by overprovisioning
your resources,
this approach is not
really cost effective.
So this pattern
allows you to apply it
to interactive and
batch workloads.
But when you're dealing
with interactive workloads,
you must determine how
to distribute requests
across environments.
These three advantages
are all related.
It allows you to
reuse, or in this case,
use your investments,
and there is no longer
a need to overprovision your
compute resources on-prem.
So that enables increased
utilization and cost
effectiveness in the private
computing environment.
As for best
practices, again, you
should choose the regions
that are close together.
That applies to the Cloud region
and the Interconnect location.
You should make Cloud resources
private for batch workloads.
Those are not public-facing,
and so in this case,
you should secure and
have them be private.
And you should secure
the communication
because the data that is
exchanged between environments
might be sensitive.
And finally, establish
common identity
so that you can
securely authenticate
across environment boundaries.
Now it's time for the
more interesting part
of our session.
Scott is the Global
Container Engineering
Lead at HSBC and the Global
Anthos Product Owner.
He's also a Google
Cloud Certified
Fellow and Co-Chair of the
CNCF Financial Services Working
Group.
Great to have you with
us here today, Scott.
SCOTT SUROVICH: Hi, Amina.
Thanks for having me.
AMINA MANSOUR: Before we
start with our questions,
why don't you tell us a little
bit about the scale of HSBC?
SCOTT SUROVICH: Sure.
So before we get
into the patterns,
I'll explain about who HSBC is.
We are one of the world's
largest global banks,
and the sheer scale of what
we deal with on a daily basis
is presented in this slide.
As you can see, we're
in 66 countries.
We process about $1.5
trillion a day in payments.
We have 110,000 servers,
roughly, globally
right now-- so that's
an out of date portion.
We have data centers in
21 different countries--
that does not count where we
have large server rooms, as
well.
We have a large amount of
employees, around 235,000.
We've got 39 million
customers globally.
We process about revenue
of $53.8 billion a year,
and we have offices all over
the world-- roughly about
3,900 offices.
So it's a large organization.
And even in the IT section, we
have 40,000 IT professionals
working for us.
AMINA MANSOUR: Thank you
for that intro, Scott.
Let me start by asking
you why you would consider
a hybrid or multicloud solution
in a highly-regulated industry?
SCOTT SUROVICH:
Definitely, great idea.
The first thing
I'll talk about is
going to be the hybrid Cloud.
So in the hybrid Cloud,
as we have on the slide,
we have data centers globally.
And again, we have server
rooms globally, as well.
So we have a large investment
in data centers already.
So we want to utilize
that where we can.
But of course,
going to the Cloud
makes sense in
multiple scenarios.
So to use these data centers,
we have a hybrid Cloud solution.
It helps us with a backup plan.
So if we go to a Cloud
with an application,
we have to have a backup
plan for the regulators.
So we have to show
that if something
were to go wrong in the
links, the relationship, just
with the vendor in general,
where do we go from there?
And on-prem is a
viable solution.
It also could go to
another CSV, but since we
have those data centers, we
can leverage that internally.
Finally, it takes time to get
approval to go to the Cloud
for an application.
It can take three to six months.
Now, in that time, you
don't want to sit idle.
You might want to
refactor your app.
You might want to test
out some new services.
So with the introduction
of containers--
Kubernetes and
Anthos-- for on-prem,
if a workload fits into
that, my developers
can actually start
developing that today
and they can move
that to the Cloud
once they have the
approval to do so.
In the multicloud side, we
select the best-of-breed
for features for each CSP.
As you said, BigQuery is a
big one for the Google side,
and it's just one of
many different features
on the Google side.
There's also regional
availability.
Certain times I
have an application
that has to go into
multiple regions.
But somebody like Google may
not have a presence in China,
or you may not have
a point of presence
somewhere close to a
certain other region.
So we have to go multicloud
where it makes sense
to go multicloud.
AMINA MANSOUR: Those are
all great reasons, Scott.
Of course, we
recognize there are
many other reasons for other
industries and verticals.
But of those patterns that I
described, which patterns are
you most likely to implement?
SCOTT SUROVICH: Sure.
All the models are great.
All the patterns are great.
So the first one that
I like to talk about
is going to be the tiered
model, or the tiered pattern.
So in my previous days, we
would have our websites on-site.
And we would be under attack--
get denial of service attacks.
We'd have to engage
multiple teams--
operating systems, networking,
obviously our service
providers, and we would
spend hours and hours trying
to remediate that situation.
We want to restore the
services to our customers
and our employees.
So rather than have us deal
with that-- the whole time we're
fighting that fire,
we are not innovating
and we're not going
forward for the business.
So let's let
somebody like Google,
who was born in the Cloud,
raised in the Cloud,
knows the Cloud, and
can protect the Cloud--
we will put our
presentation layer in GCP
and products like the
Web Application Firewall,
available on Cloud
Armor, would help
us to remediate that
attack a lot faster
and not drain our resources.
So put the front end
in the CSP, but keeping
your data safe, and even
better, regulatory compliance
to have your data on-prem.
The other model would
be the partition model.
Now, we've already mentioned
that HSBC has multiple data
centers and multiple
server rooms
globally, so we have a heavy
investment in machines.
AMINA MANSOUR: But what
about the bursting pattern?
From your experience, what
are some use cases for that?
SCOTT SUROVICH: Yeah,
the bursting pattern
is a great use case for Cloud.
However, it's also one of the
more difficult ones to utilize.
And I say that
because the challenge
is the regulatory issues that
we deal with in this industry.
So because of that, I can't
just select any workload
and say, OK, I'm going to burst
when I need to in the Cloud.
It has to be an application
that is approved,
the data has to be approved.
So we have to be careful.
So with the right choice,
it's the perfect scenario
for the challenges
that it addresses.
And 2020 was one of
those challenges.
So, of course, during
2020, a lot of people
started working from home.
Basically everybody
If you had to expand your
data center for certain use
cases because of this
different working pattern,
you might have to
expand out and scale out
your server infrastructure.
That was a big
challenge in 2020.
Trying to order
equipment was delayed
for months due to
manufacturing, due to shipping,
or due to silicone shortages.
So we can't wait
months for that.
So to address this, first
thing is the perfect scenario.
It's a little bit longer
than normal temporary,
kind of like what
you were mentioning
during your introduction,
but at some point
we do hope that all of
this is going to die down,
everything's going
to be good, and then
we all get back to
the office-- we don't
need all that extra capacity.
So by scaling up and
bursting into the Cloud,
we do it faster,
we do it cheaper,
and we don't have any of
that hardware left over
after we're done with all
of the nightmare of 2020.
AMINA MANSOUR: 100%.
You hit the nail on the
head with this example.
But let's pivot to
something happier.
What's a fun use case
for the edge pattern?
SCOTT SUROVICH: Yeah,
the edge pattern
is one I've always liked.
So in the banking industry,
a lot of processes,
a lot of hardware,
started to look at that.
So ATMs-- we're not
quite there yet,
but that's a great
use case for an edge.
From an HSBC view, though, the
edge case I like to bring up
is something called Pepper.
Pepper is actually a
robot, originally developed
by SoftBank, that we
have in 22 branches.
And what Pepper does is
it will greet the customer
as they come in.
So banking isn't exciting.
We all kind of know that.
Pepper makes it exciting.
So when you walk
into this branch
and you see this robot with
a really cute face looking
at you with an LCD and touch
screen, you can walk up to her
and you can choose what you
want to talk about to CSR
or what products you
might be interested in.
Not only is it fun
and interactive,
but it cuts the wait time
down for the customer.
This all goes into a system
that the CSR will see
and then they can walk
out to get you and know
exactly what you need
before four other people ask
you the same questions.
You go right to the person,
they know what you need,
and they can process your
request really quick.
Now aside from the cool factor--
it does bring people
into the branch.
So people want to see Pepper--
taking pictures, posting them.
We get our brand out there.
But it can go further than
just this basic stuff.
So internally, Pepper is limited
to about four core M processor
with 4 gigs of RAM.
It can do a lot of processing.
It can talk to systems
locally so we can figure out
what we need for you.
But to make it more
fun and to expand it,
we can connect that
into the Cloud.
So of course, using
something like Google,
we can use translation
services, text-to-speech, AI
interactions.
And one of my favorite
ones that we've
been debating, with consent,
would be facial recognition.
So Pepper can greet you when
you walk into the branch
and it can say,
"Welcome back, Amina.
Would you like to
look at this service?"
Or just having a
conversation with you
using the AI interaction.
AMINA MANSOUR: That's amazing.
I personally hope to
meet Pepper someday.
I know that HSBC leverages
BigQuery for some analytics
workloads, so tell
us a little bit more
about the analytics
pattern there.
SCOTT SUROVICH: Yeah.
We're a bank, we
get a lot of data.
We have a lot of things that
we have to sift through,
look at, do analysis on.
So BigQuery is very popular
among our developers,
and that's at a global scale.
So with BigQuery, as you said
during the introductions,
it can process your data,
handle millions of queries
per second, and without
us having to expand
and install hardware for this.
Now, in the earlier
days, we used to do this.
We would run things that
would take two weeks.
It would run at a bunch of
kit that we also had DR for,
because if we didn't
have a problem of fraud,
we'd have to put it to
DR. It's a lot of money
that when you're not processing
anything, it just sits there.
So aside from just being
slower and costing more,
we wanted to go to
the Cloud for that.
So one of our
applications that we did
happen to move used to take
about 10 days to process
the information.
It sat on a lot of kit, and
for the rest of that month
it just sat.
So it takes up power,
it takes up cooling,
it just takes up
general maintenance.
We have to pay for a lot
of stuff that isn't in use.
By moving it over to
BigQuery, we only utilize
or we only get charged
when we're utilizing it.
It also cut our processing time
on that operation from those
10 days down to less than a
day, and on certain operations
down to a couple of hours.
So we get the
information analyzed
much quicker and cheaper.
And there really is
nothing better, and faster,
and cheaper, and it's done well.
AMINA MANSOUR: That's a
great use case for BigQuery
and the analytics pattern.
Thank you so much for
joining us today, Scott.
It is great to learn
about all the innovation
that Google Cloud products
enable for our customers.
SCOTT SUROVICH: Great.
Thanks, Amina.
It's my pleasure to be here.
AMINA MANSOUR: If you'd like
to continue learning more
about the different
multicloud and hybrid patterns
and how to implement those
using Google Cloud products,
please check out
these sessions here
that will talk about Anthos,
for example, as the control
plane supporting that
multicloud or hybrid patterns,
as well as different
examples with Cloud Run
running in hybrid or
multicloud environments,
all the way to
extending your Anthos
or multicloud environment to VM
workloads on-premises, as well.
Thank you so much for
joining the session today,
and hopefully it was useful.